kabbalah has become something of a
popular and cool thing today
for example madonna very famously
started practicing it a few decades ago
and there's a general interest in
kabbalah in from various places
including from new age movements
now kabbalah is usually described as
jewish
mysticism and it has been around for a
very
long time of course there have been
forms of jewish mysticism that does not
fall under the category of kabbalah
and so to simply equate the two would be
to oversimplify things but at the very
least kabbalah is certainly a tradition
within judaism
that contains aspects that we would
certainly call mystical
now this is of course a vast and
unreasonably complicated and complex
tradition
that takes years and years of practice
to
grasp let alone explain but
certain aspects of kabbalah has become
very famous around the world
including the system of the ten spherot
and the famous book called the zohar
are aspects that come to mind for most
people when they hear the word kabbalah
if they've even heard about it at all
but kabbalah like most things in the
world is
very complex it's multifaceted and
diverse
there isn't just one kabbalah but a
multitude of different expressions
the most famous form of kabbalah the
kabbalah of the ten spirot and the zohar
is often referred to as theosophical
kabbalah by scholars today
this is a heavily speculative
philosophical and systematic
form of the tradition what we'll talk
about today is
not this kind of kabbalah instead we'll
be focusing on a man who
lived at the same time that the famous
zohar was most likely
composed but who represents a very
different approach
to jewish mysticism he is considered the
founder of a school of kabbalah known as
ecstatic kabbalah or prophetic kabbalah
and his name was abraham abulaffia
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this video is a collaboration with dr
justin sledge from the channel esoterica
now he will be diving a bit deeper into
certain aspects of abu lafa's
thinking including his very interesting
relationship between
the his philosophical rational side and
the more mystical
aspect of his thought so don't forget to
check out his channel it's
it's wonderful wonderful youtube channel
talking about
esoteric subjects kabbalah alchemy
hermeticism all of these very very
interesting subjects so
please go check out his channel check
out his companion video to this one and
say hello from me i would also like to
thank all of my patrons as always for
sponsoring this channel
a couple of new ones include brian king
kamal uttaj raid kolbas
and mary carmen ordonez if anyone else
would like to become a patron i will
leave a
link to all of that stuff in the
description and in the comments section
or you could also support the channel by
leaving a one-time donation
and all of that will also be available
in the description
below now on to the video
abraham been samuel abbalafia was a
jewish mystic and philosopher
who is both greatly admired but also
quite controversial as
mystics tend to be he was born in
saragosa in spain in the year 1240
but grew up for the most part in the
city to dela
this was a time and place of huge
intellectual flourishing and political
instability now in this series of videos
we have talked about many of the mystics
and philosophers of the islamic world at
around the same time
and it was indeed a time of intense
activity both politically and
intellectually
and the jewish context that abuelavia
was born into was one that was
also experiencing a lot of activity and
intellectual debate
the great philosopher maimonides perhaps
the greatest philosopher in jewish
history
had died only a few decades earlier and
his works and ideas were at this time a
point of great contention
maimonides philosophy and thus also
theology
was one that was heavily rationalistic
and grounded in aristotelian philosophy
and his interpretation of core aspects
of judaism in light of this learning had
an enormous impact on the jewish world
but it also had a lot of critics and by
the time of abu lafaye's life this was a
huge debate that was raging across the
community
and which represented large discussions
regarding the legitimacy of using
philosophical speculation to understand
the bible
or religion generally as one part of
this debate we also see the appearance
and flourishing of kabbalah
at around this time perhaps best
exemplified by the composition or at
least compilation
of the great work known as the zohar
which was most likely written or again
at least compiled by the figure moshe de
leon
during the late 13th century abulafia
would take a clear side on the
maimonides debate as we will see
but also found a very interesting way to
incorporate many of the currents of the
time while introducing some unique
things of his own
the life or biography of abu lafa is not
as much of a mystery to us as many other
figures like him because in his writings
he actually includes a lot of
biographical information
that gives us a good idea of what he did
when he did it and why now of course
because this is his own writings
the information should be taken with a
grain of salt but i think the general
outline can be trusted to some degree
while growing up in northern spain or
catalonia
abulafja studied the torah and talmud
with his father and was given a formal
education in the religious subjects
it is told that in the year 1260 at the
young age
of 20 ab bulafia left his home region of
catalonia
and traveled to the holy land to find
the mythical cembation river
where the lost tribes of israel are
thought to be located
however his mission didn't succeed as
the region was ravished by a great
conflict at the time
abelafia writes himself quite but i
could not get further than acre
because of the conflict between ishmael
and esau
indeed at the time the mamluks were in
open war with the invading mongol armies
which made the region not very safe
so abalafa was forced to cancel his
ambitious plans
and instead went overseas to greece and
italy
where he had an intense period of study
the following couple of years were
probably some of the most formative
of his entire life he had married on the
way back to europe and it is here while
staying in greece and italy
that he for the first time became
formally acquainted with
philosophy in a general sense but also
particularly with the writings and ideas
of maimonides
he studied maimonides greatest work the
guide for the perplexed
with a rabbi hillel and became a devoted
student or follower
of maimonides so much so that he would
spend much of the rest of his life
defending maimonides against his enemies
and even wrote three separate
commentaries on the guide to the
perplexed
which is more than any other major
thinker in history
after becoming thoroughly steeped in
maimonidean philosophy
abulaffia then returned to his home
region of catalonia
and settled in the city of barcelona
this was the home of the leading jewish
scholar of the time nahmanedis
but also most significantly it was a
major center for the developing
tradition of
kabbalah these two currents in judaism
at the time which are sometimes
portrayed as intellectual opposites
philosophy and kabbalah would both
become very significant parts of abu
lafar's life and teaching
as while living in barcelona he would
dive head first
into the kabbalistic tradition and the
literature of jewish mysticism generally
this included studying the so-called
theosophical kabbalah of the ten spirot
which was kind of the new hot thing in
the neighborhood but it also included
studying texts like the seifer raziel
and the very mysterious safer yet syrah
generally this region at the time was a
melting pot of
so many different ideas and traditions
many works of sufism were translated
from arabic into hebrew
and it is thus very possible that abu
lafar was familiar with the works of his
fellow spaniard ibn arabi and also other
sufis at the time
other original works that abu lafar
studied like bahib and pakudas book of
the duties of the heart
contains clear elements and influences
from sufism
and may thus have had an impact on the
later teachings of abbalafar himself
in the later writings and teachings of
abu lafaye's ecstatic kabbalah
this period becomes very central the
arguably the two most important works
for abu lafa and his
teaching is on the one hand maimonides's
guide for the perplexed
and on the other hand the safer yet an
ancient
book of jewish mysticism that describes
the creation of the world through the
letters of the hebrew alphabet indeed so
important
is all of this to abulafja that he
considers a firm grounding in both of
these traditions
both a grounding in philosophy but also
in the more
sort of theosophical kabbalah as
prerequisites
for even entering unto his own ecstatic
ecstatic practices and ecstatic
tradition
in any case abu lafaye's life still has
a lot of
eventful periods even after this for
example in the year 1270
he had a major spiritual vision which
would become the starting point for
a lot of his future endeavors this was
indeed only one of a series of visions
and experiences that would dictate his
life from then on
because from this point onwards abu
lafla believed had been given a
very exalted position his experiences
were prophetic in nature and he was now
convinced
that he was a prophet not only did he
view himself as a prophet
but indeed as the very messiah who would
eventually be revealed and end the
dominion of christianity
to reinstate the glory of the true
religion
and it is from the late 1270s onward
that abulafa starts his major activity
as a spiritual teacher
he starts to travel again moving around
constantly doing missionary activity
he taught maimonides guide to the
perplexed in places like
italy and started to develop his own
very unique
form of kabbalah in his writings and the
teachings that he presented to some of
his students at the time
he presents a version of kabbalah that
is quite different
from the theosophical version of the
zohar
abulaffia's main focus was on the divine
names
the letters of the hebrew alphabet and
various meditative techniques
that would help the practitioner reach
an ecstatic
mystical experience of union with the
active intellect and
ultimately with god himself he called
his teaching the prophetic
kabbalah and it is referred to either as
this or as
ecstatic kabbalah by scholars and people
today his claim to be a prophet was of
course rather controversial
not only did mainstream judaism teach
that prophecy had ended during biblical
times
but also that a prophet could only
appear in the holy land
and abu lafar did not meet any of these
requirements
but when abuelavia refers to himself as
a prophet
this doesn't necessarily mean what we
usually mean when we talk about prophets
he isn't an especially chosen messenger
who relays the word of god
in a direct sense very significantly abu
lafa views the mystical experience of
uniting with the active intellect or god
as essentially a prophetic experience
anyone who can reach and experience this
state of consciousness
can thus be considered a prophet and it
was abhalafia's job to be a guide to
help other people reach prophecy
as well similar points can be made for
his claim to be the messiah
he didn't really understand this concept
in the more traditional way
he didn't see himself as establishing
some earthly kingdom of god or a new
jerusalem as such
instead his messianic activity was an
esoteric
and internal one he was to bring about
an inner spiritual transformation to the
jews and the other peoples of the world
by again revealing the secrets of the
divine names
and teaching people to through the use
of these names
reach prophetic ecstatic experience
in the words of scholar eliot r wolfson
quote
on this score the messiah is not a
literal historical figure
the proverbial one who is coming in the
future but instead a metaphorical
denotation of the intellect or to be
more exact
the process of conjunction that unites
the human
and divine anyone who attains the state
of unification can be considered to have
achieved this status of the anointed one
and it is in this sense that abualah
identifies himself as the messiah
that is he is the one to reveal the
knowledge of the name that facilitates
the ecstatic experience
which renders every individual messianic
but at the same time
he did indeed see himself as a messiah
that was to bring a kind of earthly
change as well
he seems to have predicted an
apocalyptic event that was to take place
in
either 1290 or 1291 in which he would be
revealed
to the world as the messiah and after
which the rule and dominion of
christianity would be brought down with
the help of his teachings
these messianic pretensions can be seen
by the fact that he
traveled around a lot after this point
doing
various kinds of missionary activity he
was a lot in
sicily he was in in italy in the italian
mainland he was in greece and maybe even
all the way to
france but no event can showcase
this kind of messianic fervor more than
an event that allegedly took place in
the year 1280.
in a vision that abuddhafia had a few
years before
he had been told that he was to travel
to rome
to meet the pope in order to convert him
to judaism
and this conversion of the pope would be
the instigating event
of the transformation that was to
culminate 10 years later
in 1291 and indeed he took this very
seriously
in 1280 abuelavia set off to meet pope
nicholas iii
at his summer residence in soriano the
pope himself
apparently found out about abelafa's
plans and made sure to send a message to
him saying that he was indeed welcome
and that they had prepared a nice pile
of wood on which abu lafa would be
burned when he arrived
but in spite of these threats the jewish
mystic still went ahead with his plans
to go to the castle
and quite amazingly it is said that
right before or as
abulaffia was to arrive the pope
suddenly
died now this is actually a confirmed
historical event that we can find in
various
archives like the vatican archives for
example luckily for abalafa this
probably saved his life as instead of
being burned at the stake
he was instead just imprisoned for a
while and then released
and abalaf of course saw this as a great
win and as
as a sign of his great prophetic or
messianic
identity and for the next ten years
abulathy would continue
to teach and travel around this region
he
especially spent a lot of time in italy
and especially on the island of sicily
but his very bold claims of prophecy of
course didn't go unnoticed
and he soon found himself under attack
by other
jewish authorities and scholars concern
was raised about him and one of the
leading scholars in barcelona at the
time
rabbi solomon bin abraham ibn adrit
started an
all-out war against abu lafaye in many
letters and statements solomon eben
addret
gravely criticizes abuelafia as a
trickster and a fraud
among other things he wrote quote that
trickster
may the name of the wicked wrought
abraham who set himself up as a prophet
and messiah in sicily
who seduced with his falsehood some of
the children of israel
and had i not slammed the door in his
face by the mercy of god
with his imaginary and false teachings
he almost got going and would have
annihilated the community
very harsh words indeed and of course a
condemnation
from such a leading jewish scholar at
the time left a huge black
mark on abalafia's reputation he spent
the last
years of his life often responding to
these accusations
while also continuing to teach his
ecstatic kabbalah
due to this criticism he even had to
hide for a while on the island of
contino near sicily
and it seems that his last years were
indeed spent around this area
probably in sicily itself the year 1291
which abu lafa had prophesized as being
the apocalyptic turning point when he
would be revealed
as the messiah came and went without
anything particularly spectacular
happening
but it is also this year that all
information about abalafa stops
there is no trace of him after this date
which has led
most scholars to conclude that he must
have died at around this time
others might speculate that the fact
that this great event that he had been
expecting never actually happens
may have something to do with his sudden
disappearance but even if habilaffias
claims to be the messiah
never really came to fruition that
doesn't diminish the fact that he was
still a
brilliant thinker mystical teacher a
kind of genius
who introduced a new form of kabbalah
one that implemented both maimonidean
rationalistic philosophy
but also the mysticism of the
severiatsira and the
ideas about the divine names and the
letters of the hebrew alphabet
and while solomon ibn adhrat's
condemnation at the time did leave a
black mark on his reputation in the
immediate aftermath of his life
to some degree balafi has very much been
redeemed today and is often considered
a great a great scholar and teacher and
is very much admired today
for example the great modern jewish
mystic rabbi haim joseph david azulai
wrote i say that in truth i see him as a
great rabbi
among the masters of secrets and his
name is great in israel
and none may alter his words for he is
close to that book mentioned
and his right hand shall save him in
abulathya's ecstatic or prophetic
kabbalah
there is a huge emphasis on spiritual or
mystical practices
that is to elevate the soul to the world
of intellect
one of the most interesting aspects of
abu lafa is that he straddles boundaries
that we often conceive
about religion or mysticism and
philosophy
and especially the relationship between
these two at
this time and in this particular context
when we talk about medieval judaism
it is often portrayed as a dialectic
relationship consisting of maimonides
rationalism on the one hand
and the kabbalah or mysticism on the
other
being polar opposite understandings of
judaism that were in constant conflict
and while it is certainly true that this
was a real debate at the time
abulafi is a perfect example to show
that things aren't so
simple in fact abolafa is characterized
by the fact that he is a strong and
staunch supporter
of maimonides and his rationalistic
interpretation and understanding of
religion
but certainly he is also a follower of
the tradition of kabbalah and
definitely a mystic and neither are
these aspects two
different personalities or aspects
within him
that are in conflict in some way instead
he
harmonizes them and brings them together
in a very interesting way
that becomes the very unique and
fascinating
teachings that he is characterized by
now this aspect of abu lafa and his
relationship between his philosophical
thinking and his very mystical
side will be discussed at great length
by dr
justin sledge over on the channel
esoterica
this video is actually a collaboration
with him and his video this his
companion video to this one
will be tackling that question in
particular so don't forget to go watch
that after this
i also say that abu lafa was a cabalist
but this too needs to be nuanced to some
degree
as we saw from his biography he did
study the kabbalistic tradition
in barcelona which was kind of the
center of this tradition at the time
and he also dove head first into earlier
jewish mysticism
including again the book of the seifer
yet or book of formations
but there seems to be some debate among
scholars about abalafa's relationship
to that other form of kabbalah the
theosophical
kabbalah again the theosophical kabbalah
is the form most people are familiar
with it is the kind that talks about god
as ayn sorf or the infinite and of the
emanations of the ten spirot
best exemplified in the monumental work
of the zohar
some scholars argue and some of his own
writings suggest
that abalafa did to some degree at least
belong to this tradition
that he viewed the study of the
theosophical kabbalah
to be a prerequisite for entering upon
his ecstatic or prophetic path
this seems to imply that the mystical
techniques and ideas that abuela
presented
was only an extension of the
theosophical kabbalah
a deeper form only meant for the most
advanced students
others including the great scholar moshe
idel argue that abulafia was actually
very critical of this other branch of
thinkers
making his form of kabbalah an
independent and quite different school
of thought
this complex doctrine of divinity was
alien to the spirit of abelafia
who sees in it a danger of heresy he
accuses certain capitalists apparently
referring to ibn adrit
among others of being even worse than
christians
while the latter believe in a triune god
the spherotic catalyst believe in a
system of
ten distinct divine forces but
regardless of his position regarding the
other cabalists of his day
we can all agree that he certainly
emphasized different things in his
teachings
instead of complex speculation on
different metaphysical forces
apolaphia's mysticism is practical and
at least depending on how you look at it
simpler the core of abalafa's teachings
is arguably the
mystical experience because the ultimate
goal for him and for those who followed
his teachings
is to attain prophecy or ecstasy
in other words through various mystical
practices which we'll get into
abulatha tells us that the person can
reach a complete
union with the divine active intellect
and ultimately
probably even with god himself this
cleaving to god or
devkut in hebrew is a central idea for
abulafja
but it is one that can be quite elusive
so what does any of this mean really
uniting with god is a term that is used
by many people in history but it can
mean
quite different things depending on
who's talking and
how is this experience reached we can
start by exploring the philosophical or
theological positions of abelafia he was
jewish of course so his whole outlook is
based on this fact
this means for one thing that he is
strictly monotheistic
but as we have seen abu lafa was also a
huge fan of maimonides
who lived only a few decades prior and
we can see this mirrored in many of his
ideas
he follows maimonides and thus also
aristotle
in identifying god essentially as pure
intellect pure intelligible and act of
intellection
this makes a lot more sense to you if
you have a background knowledge in
philosophy
but intellect is conceived of as a kind
of mind or
awareness so whereas the neo-platonists
and
thus many other jewish thinkers of his
day would conceive of god as being
beyond
intellect and being hidden as the
unfathomable one
the hardcore aristotelians like
maimonides and abulafia
understood god as being intellect itself
and this becomes very important for
understanding his ideas of mystical
union which we will see soon
he also follows his philosophical guide
and having a very rationalistic
understanding of religion
revelation and its teachings are
understood through the filter
of reason and logic so this is an
important aspect to have in mind at
first when talking about abulafa
he is a maimonidean rationalist who
understands his religion through this
lens but at the same time he undeniably
has some pretty wacky ideas too
another one of the most important
aspects of his teachings
is the doctrine and practice involving
the divine names
and the letters of the hebrew alphabet
so important is this aspect of his
teachings that even uses it as a
designation
for his kind of kabbalah as compared to
the primarily spanish theosophical group
the latter he calls the kabbalah
tasfirot the kabbalah of the spherot
and contrasts this with his own kabbalah
shemot
the kabbalah of the divine names now
this is one of those things that is
very hard to explain in a short video
like this but it is an aspect that is
central
in order to fully understand abulaffia
he takes much of his ideas about this
subject from the seifer yet
the book of formations which is an
ancient jewish mystical text that
explores the creation of the universe by
god through the twenty-two letters
of the hebrew alphabet similar to
developments in other mystical
traditions at the time including sufism
abulafia believed that language was a
very powerful thing
words and letters were not just
arbitrary symbols representing various
things based on social conventions
as many of us hold today instead the
connection between language and the
actual realities of things in the world
was seen as a lot more strong and direct
there is a metaphysical connection
between the word
cow and the actual animal that is
referred to
language is eternal in that sense and
not just based on social conventions
to abulafja this is of course especially
true for the hebrew language
after all the language in which the
torah is written and thus the most
exalted
being directly connected to divine
revelation he thus belongs to that group
of thinkers who felt that letters and
words had a very
important role to play not only in the
ontological structure of the world but
also in terms of mystical and spiritual
practice
to abelafia the divine names mentioned
in the tanakh
and torah and the letters of the hebrew
alphabet have very strong
powers that could be utilized in
different ways to advance on the
spiritual or
mystical path their outer forms
represent
inner spiritual realities that connect
them to the divine
just like there is a direct connection
between the word cow
and an actual cow so there is a direct
connection between a name of god
and god himself and all of this becomes
central aspects of the mystical
practices that are at the core
of abu lafa's ecstatic or prophetic
kabbalah
after all what is essential to abdi's
teachings is spiritual practices we
could talk all day about his
theoretical philosophical ideas and
maimonides and rationalistic philosophy
and all of this but if we limit
ourselves only to that
we kind of miss the whole point the
theosophical cabalists of the sverot
were highly speculative
whereas abulafja put most of his
emphasis on the practical means of
reaching prophecy
techniques that helps the mystic leave
behind the world of imagination
and the material world both often
identified with satan
and to wake up to the divine world of
intellect within
a place where our true home and source
is realized
and where we can cleave or unite with
the active intellect and even with god
himself
luckily for us we have a lot of writings
by both abuelafi himself and
some of his followers that gives
instructions and accounts of
many of these mystical practices in
great detail
the content of abu lafaye's ecstatic
kabbalah consists of what we can
in a very broad sense called different
techniques of meditation
and many of these techniques can
sometimes be very elaborate
first of all above it tells us that
before going into any kind of such
meditation
one should be ritually pure and clean
and also in seclusion quote be prepared
for god or israelite
make yourself ready to direct your heart
to god alone
cleanse the body and choose a lonely
house where none shall hear your voice
sit there in your closet and do not
reveal your secret to any man
if you can do it by day in the house but
it is best if you complete it during the
night
in the hour when you prepare yourself to
speak with a creator and you wish him to
reveal his might to you
then be careful to abstract all your
thoughts from the vanities of the world
what follows these preparations are very
intricate techniques of concentration
which usually involves the divine names
abholavia teaches us to
recite the names of god both internally
but also vocally
a practice that we of course recognize
from many other religious traditions
including
sufism hinduism and the hesachasm of
orthodox eastern christianity
but what is so unique about abbalafi's
technique is the way that implements the
letters of the divine name so hebrew
letters
and combines them in various ways
quote one must take the letters first as
instructed in the written form which is
an external thing
to combine them and afterwards one takes
them from the book with their
combinations
and transfers them to one's tongue and
mouth
and pronounces them until one knows them
by heart
afterwards he shall take them from his
mouth already combined
and transfer them to his heart and set
his mind to understanding what is shown
him in every language that he knows
until nothing is left of them as this
quote suggests
abulatha's technique involves taking the
letters of various divine names
often those of the tetragrammaton yod
here
and combining them with one another as
well as with letters of other divine
names
this is done first in written form on a
piece of paper in front of oneself
it is also then recited vocally until it
is finally entirely internalized
these recitations of letters involve
various breathing techniques reminiscent
of yogic practices
as well as movements of the head and
hands this recitation practice is as
i've said
quite reminiscent of other mystical
practices but it is also quite unique in
some ways
whereas other meditative techniques will
often focus on
emptying the mind to be silent in order
to reach
some ecstatic experience or through
different mantras that eventually become
trans-inducing through there as a
repetitive nature
abulafa system of reciting the letters
and names
is one of cycles that are constantly
evolving so it never becomes repetitive
in the same way
this keeps the mind concentrated
and and focused at all times so it's not
a way of
emptying the mind to reach mystical
experience
it's to sort of over-occupy the mind to
be so concentrated
that this in itself leads to that
transcendent experience
and indeed as a result of these
techniques at least according to
ambalafa and his followers
he eventually reaches intense mystical
experiences
that are often described by these
writers in
very intricate and often colorful ways
the experience often begins as something
very unpleasant and even
fearful now i've read a lot of comments
on my videos about various mystics that
are
critical saying you know you only
believe this stuff because it sounds
nice and comforting
i don't know what kind of mysticism
these people have been reading about
maybe it's just the kind of new age or
new religious movements kind of
mysticism
because the mystical experience or the
teachings of many of these mystics be
they
jews or christians or muslims or
whatever
often present this kind of experience as
something that is very challenging
scary and even sometimes outright
dangerous
the initial stages of a mystical
experience is explained by abu lafa as
follows in the ozar eden ganous
quote the hairs of your head will begin
to stand up
into the storm and your blood will begin
to move out because of the living
combination which speaks
and all your body will begin to tremble
and your limbs will begin to shake and
you
will
fear a tremendous fear and the fear of
god shall cover you
this doesn't sound very comforting or
pleasant to me
and it is only after this initial stage
according to abudhafya that the mystic
then reaches
a more kind of ecstatic and pleasant
experience quote
and you shall feel another spirit
awakening within yourself and
strengthening you and passing over your
entire body
and giving you pleasure and it will seem
to you that
balm has been poured over you from the
crown of your head to your feet
once or many times and you shall rejoice
and feel from it a great pleasure
with gladness and trembling what the
contents of the further mystical
experience is like
is depicted in various ways many claim
experiencing a
light emitting from oneself others see
divine names
written before them and various other
such visions
but the culmination and the end goal of
all these practices and the different
stages
is the transformative experience of
devekut
a hebrew word that is often translated
as cleaving or
often specifically as cleaving to god
this is where in abelavia's terms
prophecy is achieved and the soul and
intellect of the person
becomes united with the active intellect
and most likely as we will see
with god himself but to understand the
way abu lafa talks about this we
need to get a little theoretical again
first as i've already talked about
abu lafa adopts the philosophical
tradition of aristotelianism
and to some degree also neoplatonism by
talking about this thing called
intellect a philosophical term that can
be very difficult to grasp but it can
simply be explained as
a mind or as pure thinking
sometimes we can think of intellect as
equivalent to something like
consciousness or awareness but one that
is also active and contains knowledge
the intellect in philosophical terms is
a higher level of reality than the
material world
to abu lafa and his predecessors this
intellect is our more
pure spiritual or well intellectual
core that is often placed in contrast to
things like matter so we want to focus
on
intellect and not on the material world
because the intellect is where we have a
kind of connection
to the divine abulafja again identifies
the intellect with the angel michael
and often contrasts it both to the
material world
but also to something he calls
imagination
the latter two are often associated with
satan
while the intellect is exalted as being
divine
and when it comes to intellect abu lafa
conceives of different
levels of intellect there is the divine
intellect or
mind of god himself but then below that
there is something he calls the active
intellect a kind of universal intellect
that is the source of all individual
intellects and souls
and then obviously there are the
individual intellects and different
human beings
without getting into too much philosophy
here when abu dhabi talks about his
mystical experiences
and practices he often formulates them
in philosophical terms of
intellect it is the intellect that we
are seeking
that is the intellect that we want to
cultivate and to ultimately unite
with in these different practices we
leave the material world of our body
behind
and ideally enter into the realm of
intellect and in all of this there is
often talk about a
unitive experience since all of our
souls or individual intellects
originally come
from the active intellect the goal is to
return to that original state of unity
where our individuality becomes one with
the active intellect and is annihilated
in it
quote the ultimate composite which is
man who comprises all the spherot and
whose intellect
is the active intellect and when you
will untie it
not you will be united with it in a
unique
union another quote
he prophesized according to the entity
which causes him to pass from
potentiality
into the final and perfect actuality and
he
and he become one entity inseparable
during the act from quotes like this it
becomes clear that abu lafa considers
the
peak of the mystical experience and thus
a prophecy
to be a uniting of the soul
to the active intellect very few would
deny this
but there are also other aspects of
abalafa's writings that suggest that he
goes even further than this
in claiming that the soul can actually
unite with god himself
now this may not seem all that strange
to some of you the idea of the mystical
union with god is a
language that is used by many different
people throughout history
but this is actually a kind of point of
contention or at least has been
if this kind of idea of the mystical
union is present
in judaism the famous scholar gershom
sholem famously argued that the idea of
a complete mystical union with god
is not present at all or at least is
very uncommon
in jewish thoughts including in the
kabbalah but many today
including moshe edel who has written a
lot about abalafa in particular
argues that we can see clear indications
of this kind of language in both
abuelavia
his followers and other strands of
jewish mysticism
and in the case of abuelafa the evidence
is pretty convincing
take for example this quote from
the benefit of the knowledge of the name
of god is its being the cause of man's
attainment of the actual intellection of
the active intellect
and the benefit of the intellection of
the active intellect
is the ultimate aim of the life of the
intellectual soul
and it is the reason of the life of the
next world
this aim is the union of the soul by
this intellection
with god forever or another even more
striking section
when the mystic quote has felt the
divine touch and perceived its nature
it seems right and proper to me and to
every perfected man
that he should be called master because
his name is like the name of his master
beat only in one or in many or in all of
his names
for now he is no longer separated from
his master
and behold he is his master and his
master
is he for he is so intimately united
with him
that he cannot by any means be separated
from him for he
is he it seems pretty clear that the
soul can experience a uniting with or a
becoming
one with the eternal god himself
the idea of one's soul or intellect
uniting with god
isn't all that surprising however when
we look a little deeper into his
theoretical ideas
now the parts of oneself that unites
with god is of course not the body or
any kind of
any part of the material aspect of one's
self but it's only the
intellectual self the the it is the
intellect
that unites with god remember also that
abulafa conceives of god as
pure intellect intelligible and act of
intellection
god is intellect in the absolute sense
so when he talks about various
intellects including the active
intellect or individual intellect
it is not that these are separated but
parts of a whole
in moshe idell's words abulafia is
professing a kind of
limited pantheism or an intellectual
pantheism
quote it is worth remarking that
abulafja's mysticism
includes not only the transformational
unitive component
but also a limited pantheistic facet
according to this cabalist the various
intellectual parts of the existence
are part of one continuum we should be
careful about taking this too far and
claiming that
abu dhabi may be professed something
similar to even arabic
or the unity of being instead what is
happening here is that abuela sees
the intellectual world in particular as
being a
one continuum that starts and ends with
god god is the intellect and all
other intellects flow from this absolute
so the human being insofar as the
intellectual part of the soul is
concerned
is a kind of spark of the divine whereas
his material body or the material
world in general is the very opposite of
this
so since he has this idea of a kind of
limited or intellectual pantheism
where the world of the intellect is
really one
thing a kind of oneness this means that
uniting with the active intellect is in
a way really the same thing
as uniting with god one of the followers
of abu lafa although one who never
actually met him personally
isak of aker writes a quite compelling
section about this topic
quote i heard from the sage rabbi nathan
an explanation of this name i.e the
intellect
you must know that when the divine
intellect descends it reaches the active
intellect
and it's called active intellect and
when the active intellect descends to
the acquired intellect
it is called acquired intellect and when
the acquired intellect descends to the
passive intellect it is called passive
intellect
and when the passive intellect descends
to the soul which is in man
it is called the soul we therefore find
that the divine intellect which is in
the human soul
is called the soul and this is from
above to below
and if you shall deserve and cleave to
the divine intellect
happy are you because you have returned
to your source and root
which is called literally the divine
intellect
and this person is called the man of god
that is to say a divine man
creating worlds it is very interesting
how abu lafia uses a
very philosophical aristotelian and
maimonidean language
to explain his mystical experiences as i
mentioned earlier this is
one of the most interesting and
fascinating aspects of abelafia
how he uses both of these seemingly
contradictory parts of a jewish
intellectual
heritage of the time and harmonizes them
in this way
the mystical experience which is
ultimately something that is completely
ineffable and
beyond a description is
made sense or abu lafa tries to explain
it in a way
through this language of aristotelian
philosophy
we can summarize by saying that abu
lafa's ecstatic or
prophetic kabbalah is one that is
primarily concerned with the
spiritual or meditative practices
described earlier
employing the divine names of god and
letters of the hebrew alphabet to become
unfettered from the world of matter and
body
and instead the actualization of the
soul's intellectual aspect
until one reaches the experience of
devekut
of cleaving to the active intellect and
ultimately as we have seen
to god himself until the two have become
one and he is he you can see why he
would be a somewhat controversial figure
people who say things like this are
usually somewhat controversial at least
in
some circles his condemnation by other
leading cabalists or jewish
thinkers at the time like ibn adrit did
leave a black mark on his reputation
but his influence did not die with him
he had a group of devoted followers who
would continue to spread his ideas
and indeed as i also talked about in the
beginning abbalafiya has been
redeemed to some degree today and he is
often considered a
greatly respected and admired teacher
and scholar
his writings continue to spread and
influence later thinkers
while in the immediate aftermath of his
death we don't see his ideas being
all too popular or influential but only
a few centuries later
they would be picked up by some very
significant and influential circles
abalafa's ecstatic kabbalah had a big
impact and influence on the great
capitalists of svat
in the 16th century including on isec
luria one of the greatest and most
impactful capitalists in history
and even later still he would also
influence the hasidic movement in whose
teachings we can find many
similarities with what abu lafa says as
well as the so-called christian
kabbalah and much of the kabbalah that
we find today that is sometimes
removed from its jewish roots many of
these movements
contain elements of abulafa's teachings
so while al-balafi himself
may not be the most famous figure today
neither necessarily in judaism but
definitely not in the world generally
his profound ideas have had an impact on
some of the major religious and
intellectual traditions in our
contemporary world
regardless of your approach to this man
it's impossible to look at
his life or his ideas and not be
endlessly fascinated and
intrigued i'll see you next time
[Music]
you